vinnie yeah
like when you heard that okay
it's in verdict's end what was your gut
reaction verdicts in was i and it's
funny because i was i told y'all i go
he's he's gonna win 100 he's a winner
and then all of a sudden she's like he's
in england he's not even there he's in
england playing in a band that shows you
how much he knew he was going to win bro
he don't give up he's not even in the
states anymore no he had a show in
london he's born
he wasn't even there he's up there he
has like 95 scarves 75 bracelets and
he's just i don't know who the artist is
that he's with but yesterday he got a
standing oh like he did the last like
the crowd knew what was going on and
they were like we loved it yeah bro so
your initial reaction was i'm just
following johnny around he's not even in
the country this guy's either running
for his life or he's completely
comfortable he's completely confident
and my initial thought was because then
she screwed me kelly's like well she's
gonna win
because legality she's like she's gonna
win two and i was like how'd you and
then she broke it down and then we found
out yeah she went two million dollars
but the dude won 15 so yeah we're going
to get rid of the money here we're going
to get into the money yeah natalia
you've been you've been you've been
you know seeing what's going on here
you've been kind of slow to speak
why is that what's going on here
emotionally where are you with this um i
think uh i think i'm
i mean based on the things that i've
seen i think even media has pushed a
little bit more of johnny's depth side
i think
you know amber she came in you know she
she brought this to trial she brought
this to the world's attention
and it kind of backfired in her face you
know i think she obviously did that
because she had confidence that she was
going to win but i think when certain
events and certain things came up
uh the world and the media you know the
powerful how powerful that can be they
started pushing johnny's side and i
think it kind of pushed her out the way
um and so like him not being present i
think he knew just based on how the
world was reacting like he was going to
win there was no like maybe if fans or
buts
um but i think there's there's there's
both sides that are valid points i know
there's abuse in both sides so that's
something that you know is wrong
um
but
i would say i'm i'm was more of a fairer
like looking on more of like a fair uh
like how a juror should be yeah
you're saying i would have made a great
jerk yeah yeah yeah
yeah kelly before i get into the facts
on this what are we what have we left
out other than the facts i'm about to
leave
maybe just your gut reaction because
you've been following this more than
anybody so
uh and what ty said was exactly right
there was abuse on both sides the point
of issue here they both sued for
defamation so this was brought to trial
because of an op-ed that amber posted um
in 2018
yes i think so um and then so he and he
also had a trial trial previously
um in british court for a different um
article which he lost so i don't think
that johnny depp was quite certain that
he would win this one i think he had a
prior commitment you know he's trying
not to let this rule his life like his
general attitude but um
uh i think what she said is pretty right
like
the fact that there was a toxic
relationship here is not the issue it
was a trial about he said she said and
how it affected their careers
and but the public's perception of this
trial has been so skewed
into the metoo movement and the abuse
part um has been kind of skewed you're
absolutely right the abuse the metoo
movement hollywood reality tv at its
finest money we're talking about
hundreds of millions of dollars careers
are on the line disney fan cut him from
his wife he's like children exactly
disney caught him from prior to the
caribbean family drama there's so many
angles of the story that's why i think
america is and the world is obsessed
with this it should have been
pay-per-view adam i would have paid for
it
i would not have paid for it
but i think this affects a lot of people
in situations like this and the media
makes it into this big scene which you
can't train wreck you can't look away
from you can't but they're like what do
i do in my situation train wreck